salut aujourd'hui plus qu'un blog je
vous fais découvrir mon set up et des
coulisses de la création des vidéos vous
me l'avez demandé plusieurs fois dans
les commentaires vous ne l'avez aussi
demandé lors des faq lors de la faq
snapshot
alors aujourd'hui je prends un moment
sous le soleil ardent de ce 20 juin
devant minable pour vous faire voir mon
c'est top je n'étais pas persuadé que ça
vous intéresserait apparemment si en
source de lumière principal je suis
censé me servir du soleil je dis bien
sensé parce que parce que c'est pas
toujours le cas donc du coup j'ai deux
petites sauf de boxe qui me permette de
m'éclairer pour le som j'utilise rien de
particulier j'utilise simplement le son
de la caméra parce que la prise de sang
se fait un stéréo par contre c'est un
omnidirectionnelle donc suivant où je
filme des fois c'est un peu galère je
vais peut-être penser plus tard mme
équipé d'un micro pour les caméras j'en
utilise deux principalement si j'ai
besoin d'un point de vue personnel c'est
à dire de vous mettre à ma place avec
deux caméras différentes je vais
utiliser la gopro la hero iii que vous
connaissez sûrement je me mets ça sur le
torse la gopro dedans et comme ça vous
pouvez voir à travers mes yeux et la
caméra que j'utilise au quotidien c'est
la canon legria minihic ce qui me permet
de motos cadres et elle est un peu
limité au niveau des réglages de
l'ouverture de la balance des blancs
mais elle a un très bon sens on peut
l'emmener partout elle est légère elle a
une bonne autonomie mais déjà c'est une
caméra que j'avais avant de commencer
les vidéos sur youtube donc forcément ça
m'évite et de réinvestir et puis je
pense que pour l'instant elle convient
très bien pour le défi de cette année au
niveau de la méthodologie pour écrire
créer tourner et monter vous publier des
vidéos déjà sachez que je suis en flux
tendu ça veut dire que en général j'ai
écrit je tourne je montre la vidéo le
jour même pour vous la mettre à 17
heures j'ai pas un stock d' avance alors
forcément c'est un peu galère parce que
tous les jours vous êtes hyper réactifs
par contre l' avantage c'est justement
je peux être réactif avec vous que vous
posez des questions sur les réseaux
sociaux je peux me fier à vos
commentaires et ça c'est vraiment le
côté agréable des vidéos juste une
exception dans la semaine en général la
vidéo du dimanche j'essaye de la tournée
le samedi soir comme ça le dimanche
matin je peux dormir un peu au niveau
des sujets c'est souvent au jour le jour
j'essaie d'écrire des idées d'avant ce
jeu me fait également beaucoup à vos
commentaires que je note ici quand vous
parler d'un sujet que vous aimeriez voir
comme cette vidéo la vidéo du set up
je le note dans le carnet à idées est
comme ça le matin je feuillette ait
choisi un sujet par exemple bientôt je
vais faire une vidéo sur la lecture
rapide parce que vous me l'avez demandé
ensuite je prends une feuille de bristol
je ne sais pas pourquoi j'aime
travailler là-dessus j'adore écrire sur
les feuilles comme ça sur ce genre de
fiche je détaille tout l'idée j'essaye
de créer un schéma cohérent ensuite je
mets tout ce que je sais je refais des
recherches si je veux compléter ou si je
vais sur deux mois et je structure une
espèce de schéma avec des idées clés des
mots clés des choses que je veux pas
oublier
je tourne la vidéo ça me prend entre 20
et 30 minutes comme vous avez pu voir
sur d'autres vidéos je travaille sur un
macbook pro c'est un macbook pro octobre
et je monte sur final cut pro le dise le
montage il me prend quoi allez on va
dire entre une heure et une heure et
demie plus l'export peut-être deux
heures des fois et pendant que ce
transfert sur youtube avec pixelmator je
crée la vignette la vigne est c'est là
où je passe le moins de temps
malheureusement parce qu'il faudrait des
supers vignette mail à un moment donné
je peux pas tout faire j'ai pas
forcément la compétence mille temps de
tout faire puisqu'une fois que la vidéo
est bien passé sur youtube je mets la
vignette et là il faut créer le titre et
pour le créer faut le trouver
ensuite je mets tous les descriptifs les
mots clés je le mets dans les playlists
jeu le programme l'heure de sortie à 17
heures et là c'est pas fini mais il faut
que je crée toutes les fiches et les
annotations les liens entre les vidéos
la notation qui fait que quand vous
cliquez sur le logo en haut à gauche
vous pouvez vous abonner ça fait un lien
direct ça ça prend du temps c'est parce
qu'il prend forcément le plus de temps
mais c'est celle juste le côté
décourageant une fois que tu as tout
fait tu as encore ça à faire derrière et
après c'est terminé sauf si je veux la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux dans
ces cas là j'ai encore une étape en plus
pour créer un mini clip vidéo que je
vous mets sur les réseaux je le fais pas
trop d'ailleurs en ce moment voilà vous
connaissez mettant toute la mécanique
des créations des vidéos tout ce que
j'utilise comme matériel c'est pas un
gros c'est top c'est pas un énorme c'est
top mais comme vous vouliez le voir mais
comme ça vous avez tous les détails même
les logiciels que j'utilise
j'espère que cette courte vidéo vous a
plu n'oubliez pas de la gratifier d'un
léger pouce en l'air n'oubliez pas
également de cliquer sur le logo ou sur
la trop après parce que je fais les
annotations exprès pour que vous
puissiez vous abonner d'un simple clic
puisque le mental blog c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant un an donc rendez vous
demain 17h ciao